hey this is Lawrence with motion science
and today I'm going to show you my
process on how to create a beautiful
trailer graphic in six simple steps all
inside of After Effects
[Music]
before jumping in the process let's
break down what we're going to be
creating first let's play this through a
couple times
the first thing I notice is that the
text has an interesting concrete texture
within it and blood stands out in a
bright yellow compared to its more muted
background also notice some particles
going around some subtle lens flare some
texture and blur around the edges and
some subtle displacement within the text
itself I also noticed some Parallax and
interesting imagery for the background
now let's get into the first step which
is gathering inspiration when it comes
to inspiration my go-to place is usually
Pinterest
over the years I've accumulated a lot of
boards I keep going back to whenever I'm
in need for inspiration
when it comes to trailer Graphics I
particularly like getting inspired by
movie posters let's dive into this board
I really like movie posters because of
their overall Variety in their Styles
compositions textures colors and
typography for the project we're going
to be breaking down I was inspired by
the movie poster Fury
I really like the typography choices the
yellow against the more muted background
and I wanted to create a graphic that
lived in the same world now let's jump
into the Second Step which is gathering
assets when it comes to Gathering assets
here's a few places I like to grab my
textures from the first place is of
course texture labs
texture Labs has an amazing library of
free textures you can use for your own
projects when it comes to more animated
elements I really like the website
footagecrate this is a paid annual
subscription service but their selection
of lens flares and prisms are really
good for royalty free images and footage
I highly recommend checking out unsplash
as well as pixels now let's jump into
after effects and go through the footage
we're going to be using for our project
the first piece of footage I found on
pixels and it's this cool drone shot I
used for the background I also have some
anamorphic prism I found on footage
crate some dust particles as well as
some low-lying fog I found on action VFX
when it comes to texture I'll be using
this blue haze ramp as well as this
concrete texture really high resolution
as well as this grunge full texture for
the background I'll be using this
texture Labs film texture which is free
and available to download now let's jump
into the third step which is typography
I went ahead and created a composition
which is 1920 by 1080 at 24 frames per
second and the 4 second duration I also
created two text layers which could be
used as an end card for an official
movie trailer graphic when it comes to
fonts I settled on the impact font as it
was the closest I could find to the
original movie poster once you settle on
the font the first thing I like to do is
to fix the space between the letters
which is called the kernel it doesn't
need to be perfect but the details
matter
to set up the texture I'm gonna grab my
concrete image and place it under our
first layer of text I'm then going to
use it as an alpha matte to see the
texture through the text keep in mind
you can always scale rotate flip the
texture in order to create different
looks with the same assets once I'm
happy with the placement I'm gonna
duplicate that texture and hide our
first text layer to do the same thing
once we're happy with the placement of
the texture I'm then going to add a few
effects to make the type a little more
contrasty first let's add a tint effect
to make the image black and white and
then a levels adjustment to Dalin the
values just like so once we're happy
with the contrast you can take those
adjustments copy them and paste it to
our first texture to wrap up this part
on typography we're going to create a
controller to make sure our text can be
scaled and moved around without issue
first let's create a null layer
and rename it to text control
you can then select all the layers below
it and parent it to that node if you
want to scale the text you can press s
for scale and scale it up or down as you
wish now let's get into the next step
which is creating the background I went
ahead and pre-comp to our text layer
moving all attributes into that com to
create our background I'll first make a
solid layer add a fill to it and pick a
dark color then let's bring in our
background imagery the Drone shot we saw
earlier and pick a frame we like right
click on the footage go to time Freeze
Frame we now have an image we can work
with for our background then I'm gonna
mask out the top of the image and
feather it by around 400 once we're
happy with this we can tint the footage
black and white
and play with the levels to adjust its
contrast this being too overpowering
let's lower its opacity to 15
I like this once we're happy with this
we can bring in our texture lab image in
between the footage and the solid tint
it and adjust levels you can always play
with the scale as there are very high
resolution texture we now have some
interesting typography with texture in
it a cool background to work with let's
go ahead and prepare our comp for the
next step I went ahead and applied a
tritone adjustment layer and picked off
some colors from the movie poster we saw
earlier to create the yellow text for
the word November I duplicated the text
comp masked out the word and applied the
tint to it with the color yellow now
let's get into the next step which is
adding atmosphere when it comes to
Atmosphere I think experimenting is a
key word first let's try to see what it
would look like with our fog footage
let's drag it below our tritone effect
and composite it with the shift Channel
effect take the Alpha from the luminance
and scale the layer way up I like this
but it's a little bit too much so let's
lower the opacity to 50 this is good
then let's add some particles let's take
the footage here and drag it below our
Triton effect over the fog let's solo it
and fit it to our comp with as this is
4K footage as with all of the other
textures within this tutorial I love to
add a levels effect to really dial in
the look to my liking either adding more
or adding less
it's up to you it doesn't need to be
much it doesn't need to be perfect keep
in mind you can always combine particle
footage flip it offset it scale it and
so on let's set this particle layer to
screen mode I went ahead and imported
our prism footage into our comp below
the tritone effect scaled it and found a
nice spot for it for it to appear and
leave our composition this being too
much I'm gonna lower its opacity to 5
for the look I went ahead and created an
adjustment layer added the levels effect
on it tweak the values added the lumetri
effect on it and set the faded film to
10. one last thing we're going to do
before moving on to our next and final
step is to create a displacement map for
our text in this new composition I
imported our grunge foil texture and
blurred it by 5 pixels back in our main
comp we're going to import our
displacement map put it at the bottom
below our background layer and hide it
on the main text layer we can load the
displacement map effect and choose our
displacement map comp I set the max
horizontal displacement to 8 and the
vertical displacement to zero we have
this weird effect on the text because we
have two iterations of our text comp
let's select the displacement map effect
press Ctrl alt C to copy the effect and
its properties and Ctrl V on the second
iteration we now have some subtle
displacement to our type now let's get
into the next step which is setting up
the camera before setting up the camera
let's take all of the layers we want
animated and make them 3D then you can
proceed to create a camera 35 millimeter
works well and what I like to do is to
create an object pairing the camera to
it make the null object 3D and separate
its Dimension then I'm gonna go ahead
and select our background imagery our
texture lives texture and our solid
press P for prison position and offset
the Z position to maybe 500. this
creates some nice Parallax to animate
the camera go to the beginning of your
timeline and press the stopwatch to set
a keyframe then go to the end of your
timeline and set this to maybe 100 maybe
50. we now have a very slow push in with
the camera and some nice Parallax to
take this a step further we can offset
how the text appears in our text
pre-comp let's select our first layer
offset it by 12 frames select our second
text layer and offset it to just about a
second we now have some nice offset and
animation to our text we can also create
an animator for the November text by
selecting tracking and setting a
keyframe for the tracking amount at the
beginning and at the end but keep this
very subtle maybe to end drag the first
keyframe before the text starts this
gives us a nice nice subtle animation
before wrapping it up let's go over a
few adjustment layers that take the
digital feel out of your composition
first grain I selected the preset took
down the intensity and the size and set
the color to monochromatic
then chromatic aberration here I'm using
the borrow suit prism plugin but feel
free to use Quick chromatic aberration
too as it's a free plugin I set the
starting depth to 0.99 and the ending
depth to
1.001 this creates some nice chromatic
aberration around the edges of our text
our last adjustment layer is simply a
blur set to 0.2 with two iterations to
take out the aliasing in our text it's
very subtle but it makes a difference
now let's wrap up this lesson by going
over the steps one more time first we
went on Pinterest and gathered some
inspiration for our project we then went
on texture labs to gather some textures
and pixels for footage once our assets
were imported into After Effects we
created some text and added texture
within it we then created a background
using a solid some texture and a
background image then we stylized our
text and composition position using a
Triton effect and some color once we
were happy with this we then added
atmosphere through a layer of fog some
lens flare and some particles after
applying the look we then created the
camera made our layers 3D and created
some Parallax to tie everything together
we then added some grain some chromatic
aberration and some blur let's have a
look at what we've made in full screen
I hope you've enjoyed this lesson as
much as I love teaching it if you'd like
to see more content like this leave a
comment below